Để bảo đam ăn toàn rào thông, tương ngày mục bẩy đến ngày 1 mười tháng tắm,
con ăn hành hợi tổ chức phân luộc, tổ chức hưởng đi cho các phương tiện,
cấm. Hà chế phương tiện trên nhiều tương phố chú tâm nhằm phục vụ các sự kiện kiện nhiệm
tám mới năm các mạng thẳng tắm, cuối khánh ngày 1 2 tháng chiến và ngày hội bí thủ đô bình yên.
Không dơ thư bốn dở đến tắm dở ngày 1 mười tháng tắm,
bẩy dở đến mười hai dở ngày 1 tháng tắm, và sau dở 3 mùi phút đến mười hai dở ngày 1 chiến và ngày 1 mười tháng tắm.
Vôm, đing tiên hoàn, lây lài, đặc thư lý thải tổ đến đing tiên hoàn,
lây thải đing lấy, mwyn sĩ, chẳng tiên, đặc thư đing tiên hoàn đến vô quyền,
vô quyền, tư chẳng tiên đến lây lài, lý thải tổ.
Tư chình vinh hãn đến lây lài, hẳng khai, lây thải tổ,
hẳng rộng tư lò sú đến đing tiên hoàn,
lò sú, tư hẳng rộn đến đing tiên hoàn,
khoảng trường đông kinh giễ thục, chình vinh hãn,
tư lý thải tổ đến đing tiên hoàn.
Vào tư hãn bài, tư hãn bà trường đến hẳng khai,
bà trường đến hẳng khai và khoảng trường bên hẳng nhé nước,
nửa đường tiếp sáp vườn hoa tự đại vô lý thải tổ.
Càng cấm xe tài từ năm 2000,
sẽ khách từ mùi sáo chỗ trở lên,
chứ xe biết xe thu góm giác xe xử lý sự cố,
xe bảo vệ đông thời hãn chiếu tổ cá nhân và xe máy trình các tuyến.
Vô quyền, lý thải tổ, chình vinh hãn, mwyn hiểu hôn,
lý lầy bà chiểu hẳng bài, lý thường kịch, chình vinh đọc,
hai bà chiêu, lý thình tông, phán chú trình, chình quanh khai,
chình khánh dư, phố hế, thẳng bân, thẳng gái, thẳng chống, nhà thật, nhà chung, quán chung.
Công an hà nội sẽ bột xí hướng đi cho phương tiện trong dịch tạm cấm,
hẳng chiế, tư phía đông, đông bắt thải phố, đi phía tây,
tây bắt bằng ngược lại, tư phía bắt đi phía năm thải phố và ngược lại.